>>Steve Souders: Okay.
Is that my cue to go?
Okay.
We're having a current discussion about letting
people come in and sit up front, so I hope
we can do that.
I'm really excited to see everyone that showed
up, but I have a cold shower announcement
to make.
I'm not giving anything away.
So although that's not entirely true.
I'm giving away information and knowledge,
but nothing that physically you can take home
and give to your kids if that's what they're
expecting.
So I'm going to talk about HTML5 from a performance
perspective, but first I'm going to start
off and give a little background on my work
in working on Web performance and kind of
the motivation.
I think probably a lot of people -- how many
people here build Web sites?
Yeah, okay, great.
So I think there's something in the DNA of
engineers in general, and especially programmers,
to be efficient and optimize.
I think as developers we all like our code
-- we feel proud if people -- if we can say
about our code that it's really fast and efficient.
And so at the beginning I'm going to talk
about how we can try to work to instill that
interest and buy-in for performance across
other parts of the organization outside of
engineering.
So there will be a little preamble on that
and then we'll dive into the HTML5 stuff.
I just want to mention the slides are up on
my Web site, stevesouders.com.
If you go there there's a link to it.
You can check that out.
Okay.
So let's get started -- oh, the other thing
I want to mention is really more than what
I say and more than the words on the slides,
I really want people to pay attention to the
photos in the background of the slides.
[ Laughter ]
>>Steve Souders: Come on, we're going to -- loosen
up a little bit.
Let's go.
I mean, like the story of my life, like I
take slow things and make them fast, like
is that very appropriate or what?
I need more feedback.
[ Applause ]
>>Steve Souders: Yeah, okay, there we go.
I worked at Yahoo for a long time, eight years.
I was going to be there one year and I was
there eight years.
And about four and a half years ago I joined
Google, which was really my goal when I first
started on Web performance because I knew
the people at Google really cared about making
things fast, and it's true.
So I've been there four and a half years.
I do mostly open source stuff, so I did -- I
created YSlow, Cuzillion, Sprite Me, Hammerhead,
Browserscope.
Lindsey Simon now runs that project, very
successful project.
Jdrop, which is a great concept, but not such
a successful project, but you should check
it out.
HTTP Archive, another one I don't have time
to talk about today, but check it out, HTTParchive.org.
I wrote "High Performance Web sites," "Even
Faster Web sites."
I taught at Stanford based on the books and
I run the velocity conference.
Oh, I have to update.
We just had it this week in fact.
I just finished that on Wednesday.
So I've been doing this performance stuff
for quite a listening time now, seven years,
I think, but when I started back in 2004 I
kind of felt like the lone voice in the woods.
So really I'm sure there were people that
were working on it back then, but when I searched
for information about making Web sites faster,
I really didn't find very much.
There was a great blog post from David Hyatt
that actually really opened my eyes to where
I should look for making Web sites faster.
I should mention that when I talk about performance,
I mean that from the end user's perspective.
My goal when I started this in 2004 was to
make the user experience fast.
Now, there's another aspect of performance
which I think of more as efficiency or scalability
on back end servers.
How can we handle 10X the current number of
users with the same hardware?
Those kinds of efficiency optimizations are
also performance, but when I say performance,
I really mean speed, speed of the user experience.
So when I first started working on this there
really wasn't that much information out there
and I would try to go -- I started documenting
things, writing books, blogging, trying to
go to other teams and convince them to focus
on performance.
And it's kind of like QA or writing unit tests.
Like try to sell unit tests -- time to build
unit tests to someone from marketing or sales.
That's kind of hard to do, because it's hard
to visually see the benefit of that.
So at the beginning it was kind of the same
thing with talking about make the Web site
faster.
Yeah, we need like a couple of people to work
for at least six months.
And you won't see anything different on the
site, it will just feel faster.
And believe me, that's really critical.
And they're like no, really we want you to
add more flash.
[Laughter].
>>Steve Souders: And so fast forward to 2010,
future of Web apps.
We have Fred Wilson.
How many people know Fred Wilson?
Like one of the most prolific bloggers.
He's the number one VC out of New York City,
out of Union Square, very techy guy.
But really his business is investment, funding
startup companies.
Here he is speaking at a tech conference about
his 10 golden principles of successful Web
apps.
What's number one?
Speed.
He says, First and foremost we believe that
speed is more than a feature, speed is the
most important feature.
And he goes on to talk about with their portfolio
companies they track all of the company's
performance, speed, page load time for real
users.
And that in their experience the data shows
that when the speed drops off, the success
of the business drops off.
And that's why they do this for all the portfolio
companies that they work with.
And so I think that's to me like Web performance
has arrived.
We have a VC talking at a tech conference
about speed, like this was beautiful to me.
I start almost every slide deck with this
slide.
And actually, a partner of Fred's spoke at
the Velocity conference this week.
And in addition -- if that's not enough to
have the number one VC out of New York City
talking about performance, I'm going to run
through a bunch of case studies here that
correlate performance speed to the success
of the business.
So here's -- about two years ago Bing and
Google Search got up on stage at the same
time and talked about experiments they had
run.
Bing introduced intentionally a delay in serving
search results.
They took it up to two seconds.
At a two-second delay they saw all their goodness
metrics drop off.
Most significantly revenue per user dropped
off four percent.
And of course, these companies are doing this
on a very small sample size.
So Google took this up to 400 milliseconds
at the max.
Didn't see that much dropoff in searches per
user, although at Google scale that's a fairly
significant dropoff.
The thing that was really interesting about
this study was after they removed the delay,
they kept that user group segmented and tracked
their usage.
And it took I think six weeks for the usage,
the searches per day, and other goodness metrics,
to resume where they were before the experiment
started.
So the user's awareness of what the experience
is like is something that gets ingrained and
lives with them and it takes a long time to
build that and to recover from delays.
So it's important to stay on top of keeping
your Web site fast.
And Yahoo ran a similar study.
And for full page traffic, that means traffic
where the onload event actually fires, a 400-millisecond
delay saw a five to nine percent dropoff in
traffic.
Here Mozilla -- this is about a year old.
Mozilla, when you want to upgrade to Firefox
and you're in Internet Explorer, you get the
IE landing page, and they made that IE Firefox
landing page 2.2 seconds faster, and they
saw a 15% lift in Firefox downloads.
So for them that's their business metric,
being a nonprofit.
And this was a seminal study from Velocity
a few years ago.
Shopzilla did a tremendous performance effort,
taking their site from seven seconds to about
three seconds, and they saw conversion rate
go up seven to 12 percent depending on the
country.
This is very significant.
They saw the unique users from search engine
marketing more than double.
And this was the first study that showed another
benefit in addition to the business metrics
is operating costs going down.
So here we have the number of servers needed
to run the Web site after this optimization
dropped.
And that kind of makes sense because like
one of the optimizations is connecting scripts
together, so instead of making seven requests
to my server, I'm only making one.
Turn on Gzip so the amount of time it takes
for the response to get off the server box
is lowered and so the server can handle a
higher QPS.
And then following that a good friend of mine,
Bill Scott, when he was at Netflix, they had
-- they didn't have Gzip turned on for some
reason.
I can go into it after if people want to ask.
And he turned it on one day and the [Indiscernible]
said the Web site is down, all we're serving
is the error page.
And he said why do you think that?
And they said the traffic in our data server
has dropped in half.
He said, Nope, we're serving everything, it's
just that we turned on Gzip.
So this is probably six figures a month in
a data center that they saved.
Pretty significant.
Here's another example, Edmunds.com turned
on -- added an expires header so that their
resources through their CDN could be cached
and they saw their CDN traffic drop by a third.
So again, this is a six-figure maybe high
five-figure savings per month from CDN costs.
And then not that recently anymore, this was
about a year and a half ago, Google announced
that speed or latency was going to be taken
into consideration for page rank.
And that was caveated, it's one of two hundred
signals, it only effects about one percent
of search results, but still it's a consideration
and page rank is really important.
All of these things about a year, year and
a half ago I saw coming together and so I
coined a new catch phrase for this emerging
industry called WPO.
It stands for Web Performance Optimization.
And actually as I mentioned, I keep mentioning,
we just had Velocity this week, there were
a number.
Sequoia, Battery Ventures, Excel, Union Square
were all there.
This industry is really growing up.
There's a number of startups in this Web performance
space now.
And the elevator pitch is it drives traffic
to your site.
We see that with search engine marketing,
with page rank.
It improves the user experience.
You would think that making Web sites faster
the user would get in and out more quickly,
and it's just the opposite.
All of these studies show that page views
per session, session length all increase because
the users are having a better experience.
It increases revenue.
We saw stats on that with conversions, downloads,
and it reduces operating costs.
So this all sounds pretty good, right?
Web PO is really taking off.
All right, that's the preamble.
How many people here think fast Web sites
are good?
All right.
So hopefully if you're having trouble selling
that -- if this is stuff that you want to
work on and you're having trouble selling
that back home, you can take some of these
case studies and show people back home that
this is a good investment.
You'll actually get a positive ROI.
And maybe these will give a little guidance
on what you can track on the business side
to actually correlate performance improvements
with the goals of the business.
All right.
So let's transition into the meat of the topic.
I don't want to debate about what HTML5 is.
There's the spec.
I also mean CSS3.
It's the new stuff.
So I'm going to highlight a few things around
HTML5 and CSS3 that I think are really important
to pay attention to from a performance perspective.
So the first is if you want to optimize something
you need to be able to measure it.
And right now what we'd really like to measure
is the user's perception of speed.
Currently there's no JavaScript handler for
brain activity.
So what we've been using as an industry -- as
a proxy for that is the window onload event.
Now, the problem with that is, for example,
if I do a Google search and I click on a search
result that takes me to Whole Foods, and I
want to measure -- from Whole Foods' perspective,
they want to know how long it took for the
user to click that link to when Whole Foods
was ready.
And the problem is tracking the start time.
How do you track the time that the user started
by clicking on that link?
Because that's the user's perception time.
And what you can do is at the top of the Whole
Foods page you can put a script lock that
takes a time measurement, but that totally
ignores the time it takes for the request
to go up to the Whole Foods server, for it
to stitch together all of the content and
send that back down to the browser.
So about two years ago Google and Microsoft
formed this Web performance working group
as part of the W3C, and the first task was
to create the Web timing spec, which is actually
three specs, navigation timing, user timing,
resource timing.
How many people here use navigation timing
to measure Web sites?
Good.
It's not good that there were so few hands
up.
It's good because I'm going to talk about
it a little bit.
So those of three and I'm going to talk about
each one in a little bit more detail.
They're also working on a few other specs,
page visibility I'll touch on quickly.
Script-base animations I'm not going to spend
too much time on, but people are doing a lot
of animation with JavaScript and they're working
on making that better.
And efficient script yielding, since the browsers
are single threaded, if you have long running
JavaScript it can really degrade the user
experience.
So what can scripts do to mitigate that.
But let me talk about the timing specs.
So navigation timing actually is out.
The spec is done and it's available today.
If you look at window.performance, there's
this timing object.
And you can do things like from the timing
object you can get the navigation start and
the load event end, take the difference.
And the nice thing is that the Web timing
spec gives us two main things.
This is the first one.
This is the time at which the -- the epic
time at which the user clicked on that link
on Google.
So now the user can -- the Web site owner
can get the full time from when the click
happened to when the onload event or whatever
event you wanted to.
And in fact if you put a little time stamp
at the top of the page you can break that
into what I call the back end time, the time
from the click to when the first byte arrived
and the time from the first byte to when the
full page loaded.
And there's a bunch of other timings in there.
You can get DNS time and connection time.
There are a bunch of time values that you
can get in there.
So this has been out -- the spec was finished
probably about six months ago, maybe a little
longer.
And I think IE 9 -- no, I think Chrome was
the first to implement it.
But it's in IE 9 and up, Firefox 7 and up.
They had some bugs in the Firefox 7 in the
early days, but those are all fixed now.
It's on Android.
And I heard a month ago it's on Blackberry,
but I haven't tested that.
And here's a good URL from Tony Gentilcore
that kind of explains how you could use it
and some examples of getting different time
values.
So one thing that's really cool is Google
is taking -- for page rank is taking time
into consideration, but when they announce
that -- I'm really proud of the work from
the make the Web faster team at Google, where
it wasn't like okay, we're going to hold you
responsible for it, good luck.
We also rolled out several tools.
In Webmaster tools you can go in there and
you can see how your site compares its speed,
compares to the rest of the industry.
And really the folks who were going to get
penalized from a page rank perspective are
going to be in the lower 10%, maybe even lower
than that.
So maybe you're not awesome, but if you're
in the top 50% you probably don't have too
much to worry about there.
So that's a little help, but the other thing
that's nice to get more granularity, if you
use Google analytics, we added this time measurement
capability in Google Analytics.
I think we call it site speed -- yeah, site
speed.
Yeah, this screen dump is a little old.
I think the UI is a little difference now.
But the nice thing is when we first launched
it you had to add a little bit more to your
Google Analytics snippet, and then about three
or four months ago we turned it on for everyone.
So even if you had no awareness of the site
speed, time measurement capability, you've
been gathering data for about five months
now, four or five months.
So you could go to Google Analytics and go
and find this site speed tab and you could
get charts, and it's the usual Google Analytics
slice and dice capabilities by browser, by
geographic region, by page, and you can see
what your performance is.
This is my Web site, so I don't know what
was going on there, but that was awhile ago.
See, now it's fast.
Well, in November it was fast.
Thank you for that.
I appreciate that.
[ Laughter ]
>>Steve Souders: Oh, I think I probably -- now
it's on by default.
Oh, it's only in browsers that support nav
timing, so we really need mobile browsers
to start supporting this more.
Oh, it's sampled.
So by default it's a one percent sampling
rate.
If you have a huge Web site, like one percent
is probably fine.
And the guys have done a really smart thing.
Like they don't start it at midnight and if
you're a huge Web site you've used your one
percent by 12:15.
They, like, dole it out throughout the day.
But if you're a smaller Web site, you can
change it with some Google Analytics commands
to cover 100% of your Web site, but it's limited,
I think, to 10,000 measurements a day.
But again, those will be sampled throughout
the day, so you won't get biases based on
peak time and stuff like that.
And then I'm just going to talk really quick
about the other two parts of the timing spec.
There's resource timing.
And this is -- there's drafts of this available,
but this hasn't been nailed down.
I don't think there's any browser that supports
it yet because the draft is -- the spec is
still being defined.
But this -- if you think about it, navigation
timing is basically this same information,
but it's at the page level.
It's really high.
And what we're doing with resource timing
is we're bringing that down to every HTTP
request in the page.
So for every HTTP request in the page you
can get DNS lookup time, connection time,
total time for that to come back.
This is going to be a great mechanism for
if you're using a CDN to track how your CDN
-- or maybe you're testing out multiple CDN's,
to see how their performance is going.
It does have to worry about security safeguards.
So you could have some kind of hack where,
you know, on my Web site I have the logo from
some nefarious Web site.
And when you land on my Web site I can actually
see what the DNS time is.
And if the DNS time is zero, I know that you've
been to this other Web site.
So there are some security safeguards with
HTTP headers.
Web sites can allow or not allow cross-domain
tracking of resource timing.
And then there's also user timing, which is
really important for people building Web2O
apps, AJAXy stuff.
Something like Gmail that is open for several
hours, there's no concept of a page load time.
There's only one of those when you start it
up.
So this is, if you're doing HXE stuff like
compose, this will give you commands that
you can use to say the user is about to do
a compose operation, let me -- let me mark
a start time and then when the compose is
all done, you can mark an end time, you can
give it a label, and so it lets you define
and track any timing episodes that you care
about in the Web apps that you are building.
So it basically is like nav timing but it's
much more flexible and lets you define the
start and stop times whenever you want in
your code.
The other one that I mentioned that they are
working on is page visibility.
This one is important from a performance perspective.
Mostly from a -- from an altruistic perspective,
but it could also affect, you know, what you
are doing on your Web site.
And so basically what the spec let's you do
is detect when your page is visible.
So like one thing I do in the morning when
I come in, since I can't stand to wait for
Web sites to load, is I have this script and
I -- you know, I boot up my machine, I load
the script, it loads my 30 Web sites that
I read every morning and then I go get breakfast
and when I come back, all of the pages are
loaded and I can just go through all of the
tabs.
But only the top tab is visible.
And inevitably when I come back, if I left
my sound on, my office manager, you know,
giving me a dirty look, because there's some
hidden tab that's playing video.
And the sound -- or maybe multiple tabs that
are playing video and the sound is just annoying
and it's like really?
Like you started the video, even though like
the tab is not even visible?
Like why did you do that?
And the page visibility API introduces a way
to detect whether or not the tab of the window
is visible.
And so this is also really important, like,
if you are tracking metrics, like page impressions.
If the user opened the tab but they're never
going to go to it, but you counted it as an
impression, that's a miscount.
Same thing with ads.
Again, the example of video.
You might be doing something like showing
them, you know, stock updates or the latest
messages from friends or you might be rotating
through a carousel of photos and they're not
looking at it.
So not only are you kind of -- like you might
rotate through a carousel of photos that started
with their favorite photo, but by the time
they opened the tab they are down to their
5757th favorite photo and you have kind of
ruined the experience for yourself.
So you could use it there.
Um, the other thing that you can do is -- this
API can be used for pre-fetching resources.
So the Web site owner can decide and -- the
Web site owner can decide if they want to
pre-fetch resources maybe for the next page
and also if the page should be prerendered.
This is something that Chrome does.
So Chrome can actually prerender a page in
the background.
But one of the problems with doing that is,
again, if there are ad impression counts or
page impression counts that are firing, and
the page is being rendered in the background,
and the user actually never sees it, that's
a miscount.
So the page visibility API gives people controlling
those metrics the ability to only fire the
metrics when it makes sense.
And I think this is only in Chrome right now.
But what it looks like is you can say WebKit
hidden is the property, you can look at to
see whether or not the tab is hidden and this
is an event handler you can attach to to detect
when the page does become visible.
So we had script defer in IE for years, but
now with HTML5 the async and defer attributes
are officially supported across almost every
browser out there.
I'm not going to go into it here but in fact
I've talked for years and written extensively
about the impact that scripts have on the
user experience.
So I mentioned earlier how the UI thread,
you know, the UI is single threaded, the browser
is single threaded, so if you have JavaScript,
for example, that takes three seconds to execute,
the user is clicking in the browser and they
are trying to scroll the window and nothing
is happening because the JavaScript is blocking
any of that interaction.
And so -- so that also happens when the script
is being downloaded.
So if you have a 500 k JavaScript payload
and the user has a slow connection, again,
it can take seconds for that to download.
While that's downloading, the UI could be
blocked.
Unless you can do your script loading asynchronously.
So if you just do scriptsource equals main.js
it's going to stop the HTML parser from parsing
past that script tag and it's also going to
block rendering.
No browser in the world will render anything
below a script tag until that script is downloaded
and parsed and executed.
But you can use the async attribute which
tells the browser to start the download but
to go ahead and continue parsing the HTML
and rendering the DOM elements in the page.
So it gives the user feedback.
It's a better user experience.
The user can see the page rendering, especially
because a lot of times we put scripts in the
heads of our pages, which means the entire
body is blocked from rendering until all of
those scripts are downloaded, parsed and executed.
And so this tells the browser, download it
in the background, continue parsing; and as
soon as the script arrives, parse and execute
it.
So one -- two tricky things about this is
you can't have any document.write in this
JavaScript code because parser is already
past that point.
You are going to get very bad and varied results
across browsers if you do document.write in
an async script.
The other challenge with async is suppose
that I have three scripts, A, B, C, C depends
on B, B depends on A. But A is probably like
jQuery, so might be my biggest script.
C might be really tiny, so if I load all of
these async, which is the one that's going
to come back first?
C.
If I loaded async, it's going to be parsed
and executed as soon as it comes back and
it's going to get undefined symbol errors
because B might not be back and A might not
be back.
You can't just willy-nilly add an async attribute
to all of your script tags.
But what you can do is you can use defer.
If it's JavaScript that isn't critical for
rendering content to the page, and doesn't
have document.write can add the defer attribute.
It's pretty similar.
It says download it in the background, let
the parser continue parsing and rendering
DOM elements.
After the entire page is done, parse and execute
these deferred scripts and do it in the order
that they were listed in the page.
And so if you have those interdependencies
across scripts, defer is a good fallback.
But -- but this still doesn't give all of
the control that I think is really needed
to build a good user experience for -- for
Web apps, especially on mobile.
For example, one thing that I would like to
do is I would like to download maybe a big
script, 100 k, 300 k, 500 k, but not parse
and execute it.
It might be a script for something like popping
up a div to compose a message or address book
stuff that is only needed if the user starts
typing an email message.
But if I download that, as soon as it hits
the browser, the parse and execute is going
to happen and it's going to lock up the UI.
So I really want to get this JavaScript down
to the device, get it in cache, but parse
and execute it, depending on what the user
does.
The other thing that I would like to have
is a control over when the download happens.
Right now the spec doesn't say when browser
should download the script.
But if I've said defer, if I've said async,
certainly if I've said defer, I would like
you to do this download, after everything
more important is already done, because there's
a limited number of TCP connections that the
browser will make, and if you download scripts
or multiple scripts, then things like the
background image of the page, the logo at
the top of the page, might actually be pushed
out because you are already using the six
TCP connections that most browsers allocate
to a domain.
So we don't have control over those in markup,
but there are techniques that you can use
to get that behavior.
So this is one that Gmail wrote about quite
a while ago.
Gmail mobile team.
And it's a hack.
I think it's a beautiful hack.
So what they did was in the page, they have
-- you know, maybe 300 k of JavaScript.
I'm just making these numbers up.
I don't know how much JavaScript Gmail has.
It's probably more than that.
But they have a lot of JavaScript in here
and they just wrap it in -- in comment delimiters.
So what happens is this will get downloaded
to the browser, it will be cached, it's already
resident.
But it's not parsed and executed.
So -- so let's say this is compose a new message
JavaScript.
It pops up in div, it formats everything,
it does error detection and things like that.
So we don't really need this JavaScript to
block the UI thread for parse and execution
until the user actually clicks on the compose
button, which they may never do during this
session.
So what we do is we download the code because
we want it on the device.
When they click compose, especially on a phone,
we don't want to wait to download 300 k of
JavaScript, we don't want to make the user
wait.
So what we do is we download it, you can even
download it in the background.
It's not going to block the UI thread when
it arrives.
Now the user clicks compose, you have all
of the JavaScript on the client and now you
just find the DOM element for the script tag,
remove the comment delimiters and eval the
code.
A lot of people say eval is evil.
Doug Crawford is here today, I saw him downstairs,
he'll tell you that.
Certainly eval is evil from a security perspective.
If you are eval'ing code that you didn't generate,
that can produce really bad things.
You wouldn't want to do this with third party
widgets and ads, et cetera.
So this is code that you control, that you
generated.
So from a security perspective, it's okay
and the actual performance of eval is less
than 10% worse than just a script block.
So from a performance perspective, it's actually
down like around one or two percent.
From a performance perspective, it's fine.
So you control the code, performance-wise
it's good.
So this is a -- this is a really nice hack.
And it's perfect for pre-fetching JavaScript
that you might need but you are not sure.
It's possible that you will never need it.
So don't block the UI thread, especially for
large amounts of JavaScript.
You know, this -- might require a fair amount
of rewriting on your Web site.
So I wrote something called ControlJS, that's
open source, you can get it off my Web site.
Several big companies -- I was just at this
conference, and I found that -- including
Wal-Mart, I found several big companies that
were using this that I was really surprised
at because I don't do a lot of testing.
[ Laughter ]
>>Steve Souders: I trust that they've done
that.
And actually, who else -- Washington Post
is using it.
And I asked them to contribute back the robustness
changes they had to add.
And so the thing that I like about this technique
is that it's all done in markup.
So we can just change -- instead of script
source, having type text script, we would
say text CJS, and instead of a source we have
a data control.js source, so this means that
the browser will basically just ignore this
and you can also do it with inline scripts
just by changing the type.
Then you load control.js.
What it does is it crawls the DOM, and it
finds these script nodes and it does the right
thing.
It downloads it asynchronously, it does it
in the background.
Again, you would only do this with scripts
that aren't critical for generating the initial
user experience and scripts that do not have
any document.write.
But I think it's a little easier to get on
top of.
You can even add this execute false, which
says downloaded but don't parse and execute
it.
And then later when the user, for example,
clicks on the compose button, you can say
control.js execute script.
So that's kind of a nice alternative.
The other thing I like about it, how many
people here have played with -- with JavaScript
loader, script loaders, lab js or YUI lowered.
Some people -- the thing that I find ironic
about all of the other alternatives out there
is their goal is to help you load JavaScript
asynchronously.
They do that with a helper script, but you
have to load their helper script synchronously.
[ Laughter ]
>>Steve Souders: Anyone else think that's
weird?
Like, you know, synchronous loaded scripts
are bad.
So you load our scripts synchronously and
we will help you avoid that problem.
[ Laughter ]
>>Steve Souders: Like -- so from the beginning,
one of the requirements of ControlJS was that
you could load it asynchronously.
So you would use the Google Analytics, async
loading pattern and load the script anywhere
you want in a page and everything will still
work.
So JavaScript is a really, really big problem.
I'm -- make sure that you look at how it's
impacting your Web site and if possible adopt
some of these asynchronous loading techniques.
Okay.
Shifting gears, I wanted to talk about app
cache, which is good for offline apps and
also for longer caching.
So again, the importance of the background
photo.
You are in the desert.
You typically don't have a good connection.
So having the offline apps is really important.
[ Laughter ]
>>Steve Souders: There we go, the groan.
So building offline apps is really cool.
I think Google docs just announced that this
week or last week.
It really helps with the user experience when
you have a bad connection, you are flying,
whatever.
But also people are using it from a performance
perspective for better caching.
So this is a study that I did five or six
years ago with (saying name) when we were
at Yahoo, it's been a long time, but I've
talked to people at other big Web companies
who have run the same experiment and they
basically get the same results.
So I encourage you to run it on your Web site.
Basically we put a hidden pixel in every page,
we tracked how often people made a request
with or without an if-modified-since header.
If they send the if-modified-since request,
it means they have it in the cache.
If they don't, it means they don't have it
in the cache.
So we can track how many people coming in,
how many page views are done with a full cache,
a prime cache.
Our resources are in their cache or with an
empty cache, our resources are not in their
cache.
I talk about in my best practices setting
a far futures expires header.
Turns out even if you do that, browsers aren't
going to keep things around for that long
or for whatever reason, users are going to
come in and they're not going to have everything
in cache that you might expect.
So what we see here is that for page views,
if you look at it from the page views perspective,
about 20% of page views on any given day are
done with a -- with an empty cache.
Right?
My resources are not in the cache.
You can see on the first day, when we put
this pixel on the page, 100% of the pages
had an empty cache because this image had
never been loaded before.
After about two weeks, we hit a steady state
and we can see it's about 20%.
We ran this on various properties at Yahoo
that had different user metrics.
This was always about the same.
This number fluctuated a little bit more,
but it was always between 40 and 60%.
About half of your users come in at least
once a day with an empty cache.
So why are these numbers different?
Typically, users are doing multiple page views
in a session.
So even if they have an empty cache, they
will come in and have an empty cache page
view, which will show up here and show up
here.
But then they might do three or four more
page views, which are going to be a prime
cache, because when they did their empty cache
page load stuff got put into the cache.
So that's why these numbers are different.
But it still means people anchor on negative
experience.
So if half of your users were coming in every
day with an empty cache, and you are not taking
that into consideration, you are like, well,
yeah, it's not 300 k image or script but it
will be in the cache, for about half of your
users, it's not going to be in the cache.
So you can run this experiment yourself and
you will get the same results.
So the cache, even if you are doing far future
expires, the cache might not be doing what
you think.
And -- and here's a great study from Guy Poe
over at Blaze, now Akamai, where he shows
that mobile caches are very small.
This is another reason why things you think
should be in the cache won't be.
This was a study I did where I found that
-- I like building Web apps and putting them
on the home screen and turned out in iOS if
you do that the cache isn't used optimally.
So you can use app cache for caching.
So the way they use app cache at this manifest
attribute, you give it a file name, which
is your app cache.
Manifest is a good name I think we all intuitively
recognize what we are going to see here.
Here's your manifest file.
It has to start with this cache manifest header.
We will talk about the revision number in
a second, but you'll want to add that.
It's got these various sections, a cache section
says these are the things that I want you
to put into app cache.
The network session says these are the things
that you should never put into app cache.
The fallback section says if the user is online,
then use this URL.
But if they are offline, read this one from
app cache.
So the browser, when the user is online, will
download this one, but will also download
this one and save it into app cache.
At least right now, you have to make sure
to give this a very specific content type.
Text/cache-manifest.
So it looks pretty good.
It turns out actually it's really, really,
really hard and complicated to work with.
So here are some of the gotchas that you will
probably run into.
I know I did.
I didn't realize -- like, I never listed my
HTML document itself, .php, .HTML in the manifest
file, so I just assumed it wouldn't be put
into app cache.
But if your HTML document uses the manifest
attribute, then it's going to be saved to
app cache.
This was really confusing for me because I
had a log-in box on the front page.
And if the user came in and their app cache
was empty and they weren't logged in, the
logged-out version of the page would be saved;
every time they came back, that's what they
would see even after logging in.
So that's a little confusing.
If anything in the manifest list 404s, nothing
is saved.
You get about five meg, which is pretty good.
Yeah, so this is interesting, suppose you
change one of the resources listed in the
manifest file, like an image, you would think
that the next time the user opens the app,
they would see that new image.
They don't.
You actually have to change something in the
manifest file to make it different, and that's
why the revision number was in there on the
previous slide.
That's what I do is I have that automatically
updated whenever I update through source code,
through my source code control system, it
will automatically update that revision number,
so the manifest is always touched whenever
I update a resource, and this was really confusing
to me.
Even if you do, you know, rev the manifest
file, the user still won't see the change
until the second time they open the app.
So I think this is really interesting, and
it's a real gotcha', so I wanted to walk through
it in more detail, so let's suppose you go
home today and you build mobile Web app that
uses app cache, or a desktop app that uses
app cache, and it's got this awesome green
logo that the designer gave you, and you list
that into your app cache manifest file, so
you push that tonight, tomorrow, the first
user ever downloads your app, and the app
cache is obviously empty.
They've never seen this before, and so the
browser fetches the manifest file and in there
the logo is listed so the browser downloads
that, puts it into app cache, and renders
the app to the user so the user sees the awesome
green logo.
So now suppose tomorrow night you go, you
know, I really think an orange logo would
be better, so you push to your server this
new orange logo, and you remember to change
the version number in the manifest file.
So the logo is new, the manifest file is new.
And on -- today's Friday, so you do that Saturday
night, so on Sunday, the user -- same user
loads the app again, and the browser says,
okay, well, this app has a manifest file associated
with it.
Do I have any of those resources in my app
cache?
Oh, I do.
I need logo.jif, or i have logo.jif in my
app cache; it's this pretty green logo.
Even though I've already pushed an orange
logo to my server, the browser is ignoring
that.
That's why it can work offline.
It can say I have this stuff in app cache,
let me load as much as I can without using
the network.
And so it displays that app cache logo to
the user.
But now what it does is it's -- once it's
rendered the app with the old out-of-date
logo, it fetches the manifest file, it detects
that it's changed and so then it checks all
other resources in the manifest file and it
gets the new version of the logo which is
orange, it saves that to app cache, so if
the user reloads the app, a second time, it
will -- the browser will look in app cache
and now it has the orange logo, so it renders
the orange logo to the user, it fetches the
manifest file which hasn't changed and so
it's done.
So it's really taken these two loads -- after
I update a resource it takes two loads for
the user to see the changes.
Now, there is a work around to this, it's
not that hard, but not that easy.
There's this update ready part.
The implementation is pretty easy.
I can track this.
But it's what do I want to do with the user
experience?
So in the background, the browser detected
that there was a new logo, and it fires this
update ready, but are you going to tell the
user to like reload the app to see the changes?
I don't know, you have to decide for yourself.
Maybe if it's just images it's not that important.
If it's like an important JavaScript security
privacy fix, then, yeah, maybe you want to
tell them to reload it, or you want to reload
it without even telling them, just reload
the app.
Another way to do improved caching because
we know the browser cache doesn't work super
awesome is local storage.
Really simple API.
Local storage is persistent across sessions.
If you only care about sessions, you can use
session storage.
It's about five meg.
One warning, browser developers really are
worried about this getting too much use because
it does a synchronous read.
Some browsers will actually read everything
out of local storage, the first time you go
to that page during the session, and if you
have a lot of stuff in local storage, again,
it's single-threaded so that can slow down
the user experience.
So I built this bookmark that lets you look
into what is stored in local storage, and
I discovered a couple of interesting things
that Bing and Google search were doing, which
I hadn't thought of, and it's very cool to
help with caching.
So I think this is the Google search -- Google
mobile search implementation.
The first time you do a search, the HTML document
will return all of these inline script and
style blocks, a lot of JavaScript and CSS,
and when it's done, it iterates over those
script tags and style tags that have IDs,
and it takes the content of the block, and
writes it into local storage based on the
ID of that element.
So now, after I've done this first search
ever on my phone, I have blocks of JavaScript
and CSS in my local storage, so now let's
say I do another -- oh, and the other thing
it does is it sets a cookie that says which
blocks of JavaScript and CSS have been written
into this user's local storage.
So now if I do another search, this cookie
goes up to the server, and the server says,
oh, well, you're doing a search, I have to
give you this block and that block and this
JavaScript and this CSS.
Let me see what you already have in local
storage.
It looks at the cookie and says, oh, you already
have this block, I don't have to send you
that, I don't have to send you this CSS, and
for -- in the case of mobile search, it drops
the download size from about 110K to just
10K, because all that stuff is now in local
storage.
And then when the lightweight page arrives,
there's some JavaScript that will pull all
of these things out of local storage and write
them into the page.
So this is a really cool way to get more persistent
cache.
Local storage is unaffected by other Web sites
whereas the shared browser cache, if the user
visits a bunch of other Web sites that have
large resources, your content might get pushed
out.
So I did a quick survey using this is what
this -- I'm a good JavaScript hacker.
I'm not a good UI designer.
This is my awesome storage or bookmark list,
and you can see it lets you look at what's
in the local storage and session storage,
tells you how big it is, how many items it
is.
So let's just do a quick run through the Alexa
Top 10 and see how local storage is being
used.
So here we have -- Google search is using
it on both mobile and desktop, so that's one.
Bing is using it on mobile.
Facebook is using it on mobile.
Yahoo is maybe using it a little bit, but
not really.
We're not going to count that.
YouTube, yeah, we'll count that.
Quite a bit of content on mobile.
Amazon, no.
Twitter?
Yeah, okay, we'll count that.
Five.
LinkedIn, no, I would say.
eBay, no.
MSN, no.
So about five or six of the Alexa Top 10 are
using local storage, so that's an indicator
that, you know, it's worth investigating.
Why is it more -- maybe used more prevalently
on mobile?
You know, the experience of not having something
in the cache in mobile is worse, because the
network connection speed is so slow, also
the cache is smaller on mobile, so caching
isn't awesome on desktop, but is much better
on mobile, so I think that's why these top
properties started using local storage on
mobile, but I would expect to see this proliferate
on desktop apps as well.
So I want to talk about font-face.
Again, pay attention to the photos, not to
what I say.
So, you know, fonts, using custom fonts can
create a more compelling, beautiful experience,
but people haven't really paid attention to
what it does, similar to how scripts and style
sheets can block a page, what custom font
files do, and so I created this table that
here's the blog post, that shows how scripts
and style sheets and fonts can affect, and,
you know, "blank below in red" means that
everything using this font or below it are
going to be affected.
Flash -- oh, delayed means -- blank is really
bad.
It means like everything in the page is blank.
Delayed means just the element that's using
the font file is affected.
Flash means once the things -- things will
render, but once the resource arrives it has
to be redrawn, and so it's kind of a jerky
user experience, things have to be rerenderred
and repainted.
So you can see the impact.
Even the green "good" is not really a good
experience.
And so you want to use fonts kind of carefully.
And it's kind of ironic, it's kind of how
these async script loader libraries make you
load their scripts synchronously.
When I talk to designers about why they're
using custom fonts, even though we know it
has this impact on the user experience, they
say, well, these are the most important design
elements in the page.
I'm like, "so you want the most important
parts of the page to take the longest to render?"
Like, that doesn't make sense to me.
So despite my warnings, custom fonts have
taken off, like they've more than doubled
in the last year, this is a chart from the
HTP archive.
So they're taking off.
The good thing is the folks at Typekit and
the Google fonts library have done a lot of
good work to mitigate the impact that custom
fonts files have, but we can still go farther.
In fact, I think Google fonts library just
announced custom fonts a few months ago.
If you don't need -- like if you're only using
digits or other certain characters, like it's
just a word that you want to render in that
font, you can actually create a smaller font.
The font files are typically like over 100K,
so you can create one that is just the characters
that you need.
The flash of unstyled text means you draw
text and then you have to redraw it, and so
what I would propose is that browsers have
like an impatient fallback, like if -- I don't
want to have this flash of my text, so I'm
going to wait 250 milliseconds for the font
file.
If it hasn't come back and we're drawing in
a default font, and even if the font files
comes back later, I'm not going to redraw
it.
I'll cache that font for the next time the
user goes to the page, but I'm not going to
do that, and again, I think this is a behavior
that the Google font library and Typekit loaders
do automatically for you.
Yeah.
And also, okay, I'm running short on time,
so I'm going to go a little faster.
Font should be given a higher priority in
caching.
Browsers are still just starting to pay attention
to that, and even if a font is expired, I
might want to render with it, and do a "if
modified since request", and then if I get
back, "oh, not modified?"
It's okay, I've already rendered with a font.
All I have to do is validate it.
Oh, good, I'm getting close to the end, so
there's a lot more stuff I didn't talk about.
We -- you know, all of us spent a lot of time
building rounded corners that downloaded a
bunch of images, so now you can do a lot of
things that used to require HTP traffic, you
can do with CSS 3, so that's cool.
You have to be a little careful, these incur,
you know, might incur a lot of CPU overhead
or repaints.
You can use SVG and canvas instead of downloading
images.
Video tag could make starting up videos faster.
Web sockets, if you have a very chatty sort
of app can be used.
Web workers, if you have like a lot of computation
that you want to get out of the UI thread,
you can use Web workers, oh, for some things
that we used to have to write a lot of JavaScript
or HTML for, you can do with these new built-in
controls.
Again, the photo, more, infinite number of
digits.
History API, we used to have to implement
this in JavaScript.
Now we don't have to download all that JavaScript.
Ping is a way to avoid a redirect if you want
to track something.
Don't use set time-out for animation.
Use request animation frame.
It will be faster.
You can use the native JSON parser, and here
are some good resources to get more information
about this other HTML5 stuff.
So what are the takeaways?
Speed matters.
Hopefully we all agree about that.
I saw you raise your hand before.
So I'm going to hold you to that.
Pay attention to what's coming out of the
Web performance working group out of the W3C.
You can use window.performance to track the
timing on your pages, and even if you haven't
done that yet, if you're using Google Analytics,
you can go and see the data there.
It's already been gathered for the last few
months.
JavaScript blocking the UI thread is really
critical.
Try to get a lot of that stuff deferred or
async, and caching is really important.
I think it's one of the most important things
for a fast user experience.
Browsers are improving their cache.
Mobile browsers have a lot of room to catch
up on, so you can try some of these other
techniques.
And be careful about using font-face.
So before I close out, I want to mention,
if you like this kind of performance stuff,
I'm sorry, but you should have been at Velocity
this week.
We just finished that Wednesday.
But if you missed that, you could go to Web
PERF days, the first ever, but -- well, actually,
that was yesterday.
Okay, so you missed that one.
[ Laughter ]
>>Steve Souders: Oh, okay, we've got Velocity
Europe coming up in October, so you might
have to go a little farther, but -- and we'll
be back next year in June for Velocity.
I also wanted to just mention this -- oh,
I added this like five minutes before I came
on stage.
How can I do this, like -- I don't know, I
have to go through them all.
So (indiscernible) runs this performance calendar
every year, and O'Reilly took the most recent
performance calendar and put it into a book,
so this just came out this week, and you can
get most of this content on the blog for the
performance calendar, but the -- they were
updated, and if you like books, you can get
it in book form here.
So that's it.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>>Steve Souders: So I've got about four minutes,
I would be happy to answer any questions and
I think they want you to use the mic.
Everyone is heading out.
>>> Would you care to expand upon font awesome?
And also to resolve some of the issues of
pop-in, I found setting a fixed type for whatever
text I decide is very nice.
>>Steve Souders: What's the first one?
Expound on...
>>> Font awesome, using fonts instead of sprites?
>>Steve Souders: Oh, yeah, so you can create
a custom font, you know, file, that has little
pictures, you know, kind of like wings -- what
is it on windows?
The wings font, wingdings, yeah, so you can
do that with a font, so if you have like really
small images that you're using now and you're
downloading them as HTP requests instead of
images, instead you can download a font fall.
It doesn't have to be huge.
Maybe you have 10 of those or 20 of those,
and you can download those and use those to
draw those little images, those little sprites
in the page for like maybe little buttons
or things like that, and so, you know, I think
that's a great idea.
You could also use sprites.
Sprites are maybe a little harder to do.
You have to create the image and know all
the CSS, but the one thing I would say, if
you're using any kind of font file, is try
to figure out a way to do it that doesn't
block the page, like especially in IE.
Custom font files block rendering of everything
in the page, so if you could do that lazily
or something like that, that would be good,
and then the second one was...
>>> Just a tip to deal with font snapping
in after they loaded, the ugly hack of just
setting a fixed type for everything.
So at least it doesn't like reflow.
>>Steve Souders: Yeah, yeah, you could do
that.
Yes, another question.
>>> Yeah, you said mobile browsers don't support
most of those features yet, custom, you know,
desktop browsers either, so how would we test
them?
>>Steve Souders: I guess I wasn't clear.
Everything I talked about is supported in
mobile browsers, pretty much, and, in fact,
you're going to get -- I think that's another
reason why we're seeing more HTML5 stuff on
mobile and desktop, because on desktop, there's
still a lot more lingering IE6, IE7 legacy
browsers out there, so you're almost a little
safer using the cutting edge stuff on mobile
than you are on desktop.
The only thing I can think about is I thought
there was something -- well, the page visibility
API is only in Chrome, but all the timing
stuff, local storage fonts, app cache, async
and defer attributes, all of that is supported
on mobile too.
>>> Thank you.
>>Steve Souders: Yeah.
Okay, let's go here.
>>> Let's see here.
You were talking about visibility and document.webkit
hidden and how that relates with click tracking
and stuff like that.
One click unsubscribes and e-mails and things
like that, is that another way that we can
avoid being automatically unsubscribed?
>>Steve Souders: Oh, oh, well, but how would
you -- how would you -- what's the scenario
where you would render unsubscribed page without
the user seeing it?
>>> Well, if they're following links and pre-loading
in the background, you might follow --
>>Steve Souders: Oh, yeah, the pre-rendering
I was talking about is the developer or user
has explicitly asked to open a page, but we
can just know we can do it in the background.
But, so, yeah, if you're crawling a page,
that could be something that you could do
is to make sure not to -- you know, you could
instrument an unsubscribed link so that it
only worked if the page was visible.
Yeah.
>>> Thank you.
>>Steve Souders: Yeah.
>>> What's your recommendation in terms of
moving the script tags physically to the bottom
of the body tag versus using the defer script
tag that you described?
>>Steve Souders: Yeah, I think both of those
work.
One thing that we -- I only have a few seconds,
so one thing we don't have time to talk about
is the importance of the onload event firing
as quickly as possible, so in both cases with
defer and async and putting scripts at the
bottom, you're going to block the onload link,
the onload event from firing, so really putting
scripts at the bottom is almost the same as
doing defer.
It really has more to do with kind of the
size of your team.
A lot of times there's, you know, 20 or 200
people working on a property, and so it's
hard to get the message out to put scripts
at the bottom or like someone's code is only
going to be executed at the top and be really
hard to give them a foothold in the top and
give them also a foothold in the bottom and
make sure that both of those are done in sync,
so if the only place like the logging or metrics
team has a place to -- a foothold in the page
is at the top, they can get the same behavior
using the defer attribute as just putting
the script tag at the bottom.
Putting the script tag at the bottom is another
lightweight way to avoid that blocking of
the UI thread.
Okay.
So I should wrap up.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]